Welcome to your initiation.
In a short while, you’ll be a member of
our little family.
But there's something you should know first.
In order to be a part of the family, you must
first know the family rules and values.
So I'll need you to pay attention to all 43
Things You Missed in Sunny Family Cult.
But first you'll want to have seen the series
over on CryptTV so click or tap right here
to give that a watch if you haven't seen it
yet.
The first requirement of our group is to be
desensitized to violence.
Season 1 is all about moulding Taylor, our
youngest member so far.
Take a look at some of the things we've done
to help her along.
Notice how the house is decorated with diagrams
of human anatomy to get her to see flesh as
flesh, and nothing more.
Even as a young child, she's forced to watch
violent movies.
(Clip)
Not much effort is put into shielding her
from the violent ritual taking place downstairs.
“Come on.
Go to bed.”
Anddd…. that's about all the protection
they give her.
It's almost like they want Taylor to find
out on her own, despite her mother telling
her she wasn't supposed to see the ritual.
And when she does find out, instead of trying
to convince her otherwise, the mom smears
blood on her daughter's face.
They also hint at the idea that Taylor will
be expected to become apart of the cult when
she's older too.
At the very beginning, Taylor is upset that
her parents are leaving and her mom tells
her she'll go on lots of dates when she's
older too.
Seems harmless enough, but considering their
idea of a date involves chopping up and sacrificing
a drunk hitchhiker, they're basically planting
the seed that they expect her dates to end
in bloodshed too, and in episode 3, we see
just that, when Taylor is finally old enough
to go on dates.
This is where we see Taylor's hesitation starts
to come into play.
A part of her wants to participate in the
cult and make her family proud, but a part
of her wants to be a normal teenager.
“Do you ever just wish things were different?
You ever wish you were just somewhere different?
Like you could do whatever you want, and not
have to answer to anyone or follow anyone’s
rules?”
Season 1 ends with a huge metaphorical choice
on April 1st.
Take note, that April Fools Day is the holiest
day of the year for our family because we
are all about spreading chaos, and that’s
exactly what that day is dedicated to.
Taylor has the option to continue to fight
against her parents ways, or join them and
let go of ever living a normal life.
She chooses her own family in a huge way by
inviting over all of her friends and killing
them off, thus completing her initiation.
The moment is commemorated with a family photo.
“I think we should do a family portrait.”
Photos become a major symbol of Taylor’s
internal struggle between her responsibility
to the family and her social life.
The family loves to commemorate things with
photos.
They have like 100 cameras set up in the house
and they have tons of family photos dating
back to Taylor’s childhood.
In Season 2 she starts to make a real friend
when she grows closer to Jaina, and they take
some Polaroid selfies together, which Taylor
holds very dear in same drawer she keeps her
diary.
The selfie she took with her family is nowhere
to be seen.
The lesson to be learned?
Don't stray from the path set for you like
Taylor did.
One thing you can do to show your dedication
is get a tattoo of our symbol like Taylor
does when she's sixteen, but if anyone asks,
just say you saw it online and it looked cool,
because we use the same logo on our calling
card, which includes real human blood.
The logo itself is a smiley face with a line
drawn through the center.
I’ll get back to the meaning behind that
later in this initiation.
So that covers Season 1 and Lesson 1, the
development of Taylor from innocent little
girl to cold blooded killer.
Lesson 2 is going to be about the true purpose
of the cult and a rival cult hinted at in
both Seasons 1 and 2.
But before we get to that, I know you want
to hear about those Easter Eggs, so here they
are.
The house is decorated with a lot of repeating
symbols, like these owl statues.
They could be a link between owls, a nocturnal
predator, and the family, who makes all of
their kills at night.
Also, the killer in episode 2 has an owl tattoo.
More on that later.
When Taylor finally snaps and kills 4 classmates,
she you can see the board game Maniac in the
background behind her.
And then when her friends tell her, “this
isn't funny” she replies with, “I think
it is,” and a book titled Funny Girl can
be seen behind her.
Then in the classroom, there are some quotes
on the wall.
Many of them are thematic of the entire series.
Like this one.
It's a quote from Woodrow Wilson.
‘The seed of revolution is repression.’
You could apply that to Taylor's struggle
between her father trying to keep her in line
and her trying to revolt and live her own
life.
Normal teenager stuff, but there's a lot more
on the line when Dad's the leader of a notorious
cult.
There are other quotes like this about the
series in the classroom, but I'll let you
check those out for yourself and leave your
findings in the comments.
Then there's this S. You maybe remember it
from when you were in school.
I remember the other kids would draw it everywhere.
Constantly.
But I've never actually known the meaning
of it.
So I decided to Google it.
I just literally looked up, ‘the s from
school’, and surprisingly it turned up some
results…
however it seems that nobody really knows
the meaning or origin of it.
It actually comes up again later in Taylor's
diary along with the words Anti-Social.
So maybe it's something she draws to pass
the time because she has no friends, or maybe
she even does it to try to fit in more with
the other students.
The last find from the classroom I'll point
out is that if you look at the papers on Taylor’s
desk right here, it's actually the shot list
from this scene.
Sunny Family loves references to other horror
films.
Taylor has a Nosferatu poster, a reference
to one of the most iconic horror films of
the 1920s.
(Clip)
Then inside of the coffee shop, there's a
figurine on the counter of Giggles the Clown,
another CryptTV property, and Taylor also
has a photo of Giggles in her room.
Remember Look-See?
He's another CryptTV monster that I did a
Things You Missed on a couple weeks ago, and
a sketch of him can be found in Taylor's diary.
There's also a drawing of Mordeo, from the
Crypt short film, and her bookmark is connected
to a small metallic knife.
And whatever this thing is.
Now if you've been paying attention so far
to this point, there is probably one thing
you're a little confused about.
That is, what's the point of the Sunny Family
Cult?
In the ritual, the cult leader says the goal
is to introduce chaos and disrupt bonality,
or in other words, spice up the boring everyday
routine of life.
But in private, to Taylor, her parents preach
the value of stopping bad people and not being
a victim.
So which is it?
The reason for the duality in values is actually
because the cult itself is split.
Into two.
The last thing we see in Season 2 is a flashback
to Elias’s past, when he was first introduced
into the cult. by this guy, Roger, the guy
who doesn’t look old enough to be a teacher
because he’s lying.
“Hey!”
“Hi.”
“I don’t mean to bother you or anything.”
He’s lying.
“Are you stalking me?”
“What?
No.
Not at all.”
He’s lying again.
“The school offered me a full time teaching
gig for next semester.”
Lying!
You can probably guess he’s not a detective
either, he was an member of the cult back
in the 90s.
And he still dons the mask and the axe in
present day.
He had a disagreement with Elias in 1995 about
their differing ways of thinking.
“I’m sorry.
I can’t do it.
It doesn’t feel right.”
“You won’t know how it feels until you
do it.
Trust me Elias.”
“We’re different Roger.
I don’t always have to think the same way
you do.”
“We’re family.
Maybe you should start trying a little harder.”
We don’t know exactly what they disagreed
on, but what if this split resulted in two
chapters of the cult, one led by Elias, and
the other by Roger?
What if that’s why Elias’s cult is dedicated
to stopping to bad people and avoiding victimization,
while still sharing the motto about chaos
and disrupting bonality carried over from
the original cult it branched off from?
That could explain why members of Elias’s
cult are so different from meeting to meeting,
because he’s always getting rid of people
who don’t see eye to eye with him.
That would mean the copycat in episode 2 might
not be a copycat at all, but rather a member
of the original chapter of the cult.
Maybe Elias’s group are the real copycats
here.
--
But what was this big disagreement that caused
the cult to split?
Our only clues are in each of the victims.
Let’s break them down one by own.
The first victim is just a drunk hitchhiker.
You could argue that he’s guilty for public
intoxication, but this guy probably won’t
give us any other clues about what caused
the split.
Episode 2, however, shows the family taking
out the copycat cult member, who, again, could
be from the original cult.
They tell this guy that he’s being taken
out for going after children, and there’s
one shot in particular that seems to suggest
he might also be taking part in some cannibal
activities, though it’s never said for sure.
These two ideals may have contributed to the
breakup, but it’s also pretty clear that
the victim during the big disagreement in
the 90s is not a kid, so there are most likely
other points they disagree on as well.
The victim in episode three doesn’t appear
to be doing anything wrong, however pay attention
to this line.
“I wish I could like teleport or something.
Ooh, or not live in a dorm.”
So this guy is in college.
It’s later revealed that Taylor is only
16 at this point because her next birthday
in the series is her seventeenth birthday.
Most likely, this guy is on the hit-list because
of that.
We don’t know what any of the four classmates
killed in episode 4 did, if anything, but
it certainly brings what the mom said about
killing bad pe-ople into question.
In season 2, Taylor meets her best friend
Jaina, and shortly after, Jaina’s boyfriend
Lance is murdered by what we can almost confirm
is Roger, or at the very least, someone from
Roger’s chapter of the cult.
Not long after, an arm is found in the woods,
and shortly after that a seemingly matching
body is spotted by Taylor’s classmate Allie-Ann.
I think the assumption is that it belongs
to Lance, however, upon closer inspection,
the arm is wearing long red sleeves that Lance
didn’t have at the time of his death.
But then, upon closer closer inspection, Lance
does have a red jacket in hand just before
he’s killed, so maybe the killer put the
jacket on him before dismembering the arm
and dumping the body?
I’m not sure why though.
The guy who is killed for deserting the family
makes sense for both chapters of the cult,
they can’t have formers members walking
around who could possibly talk.
But the death of the high powered attorney
described to Allie-Ann and her friends by
the barista from the coffee shop offers up
some more insight.
Supposedly she was crooked, so she got stabbed
to death by The Sunny Family Cult and dumped
in a lake.
We don’t know how long ago that was, only
that the barista says he hadn’t seen the
symbol in a long time.
He does look to be on the younger side, so
there’s a good chance this was after the
split.
So what can we conclude from all of this?
I would theorize that in 1995 Elias and Roger
disagreed on what qualifies as a bad person.
Elias broke off from the group and formed
his own chapter of the cult.
The two continued to operate independently
until 2017, when someone from Roger’s group
chopped up… and possibly devoured… a young
girl.
After much debate, and even a little push
from his own daughter, Elias decided enough
was enough and went after the guy who had
abducted the young girl.
Now, for revenge, Roger comes after Elias’s
family, killing their friends and sparing
their enemies and in the end, kidnapping Taylor,
the girl they’ve been grooming to one day
be the new leader of the family cult.
I think it’s a sound theory, but it does
leave one question.
Who is Jaina?
If you rewatch season 2, she really goes out
of her way to befriend Taylor.
She also talks to Roger at the coffee shop,
but we don’t get to see the contents of
that conversation.
But the last time Taylor speaks to her in
Season 2, Jaina says there’s more she info
hasn’t told yet.
So what is Jaina hiding?
There’s a minor line by Taylor’s mother
in episode 4 where she mentions that they’ll
need to get more bleach to clean up the bloody
mess.
Well, in Season 2, Jaina has bleach stains
on her shirt.
Is this the latest fashion trend, or has Jaina
been doing some “cleaning” of her own.
Let me know your thoughts in the comments.
But before we’re ready to officially accept
you into our family, before the initiation
is complete there’s one more thing I’ll
need you to do and that’s to subscribe to
CryptTV, they’ve got new horror content
every week on Tuesdays, Thursdays and Fridays
and they’re getting really close to 1 million
subs.
So let’s go make that happen.
Go ahead and like this video.
And if you haven’t seen it yet, check out
my video 58 Things You Missed in Look-See,
it’s another Crypt series I’ve covered,
so if you enjoy Sunny Family, you’ll want
to check that one out too.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.